J is where the shays in st. Louis how
hey how are you hi Dave
Congrats on 25 years and thank you for
being here thank you how can I help ya I
have about two hundred and twenty-two
thousand dollars and of debt and I don't
know what to do oh my gosh what in the
world are you a doctor a lawyer I'm a
lawyer a lawyer okay and that's all
student loan debt or most of it I'm two
hundred and twelve in student loan debt
Wow
how long you been on Law School just one
year past your bar yes got the job yes
what are you making fifty fifty on your
way to 100 yeah okay and fifty is more
than you've ever made in your life it is
what button so what I'm going to
encourage you to live like a college
student and earn like a lawyer okay and
throw the difference at the loan now so
the good news is is that you're not
going to be making fifty forever what
type of law are you practicing I'm a
prosecuting attorney so I can I wanted
to get a second income as you suggest
you can i income up and i can't really
do the public jobs so I can't use my law
degree because I find a farm that
doesn't allow me to do anything else on
the side legally yeah well prosecuting
attorney staying in that role does not
have a quick escalation of income not at
all and so you're probably going to jump
out of that role and jump to the other
side at some point to the defense side
to make some money I guess yes because
otherwise you've got a long road at
fifty sixty seventy five thousand but if
I can go from 50 to 100 100 and a
quarter all of a sudden you know we can
start throwing 50 grand a year at this
two hundred and that's a four-year plan
you can't throw fifty grand a year at it
when you make fifty following so two
hundred divided by 50 is four so but you
can't throw that much at it today but I
you have the ability to escalate your
income you may have to jump out of that
get a role to do that it won't hurt to
sit there for a year or even two and get
the you know get the experience and look
you know learn the trade learn the learn
your way around the courthouse so to
speak but but long term five years from
now I don't want you making seventy two
thousand in this same job okay not not
to get out of two hundred and twelve
thousand dollar that you need to get you
need to use them you know use the degree
to make more money is what it amounts to
so but but you know the it's pretty easy
math if you put twenty five thousand
dollars a year towards two hundred
twenty-five thousand and that's a long
time so it's like ten years where you
get there we don't want to do that but
but but if you put fifty thousand
towards it it's a four year plan if you
put a hundred thousand towards it is a
two-year plan and and that's all the
function of income so keep your keep
your lifestyle down low and constantly
be looking at moves you can make in your
career track to make more at least until
you get this cleared and then you can
make different decisions if you want to
move back in to prosecute prosecutorial
direction five years from now once you
clean this up and after you've had a
little bit of practice on the other side
on the defense side or something maybe
maybe then you do that I don't know but
the debt load you took on is going to
have an effect on your career choice or
on your application of your career
choice meaning what kind of law you
practice you're going to be forced to go
make some money
at some point early in the process here
otherwise you're gonna have this for ten
years and we don't want that you don't
want that so hey thanks for calling in
if we can help you call back anytime
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]